The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This week's
problem is from the 2008 quiz
one on search.
It is motivated by the search of
evil overlord, Mark Vader, who
is shopping for a
new evil stronghold.
He starts from his
current stronghold,
which is S, the
Depth-First Search Star.
Now the Depth-First Search Star
has the following qualities.
It has a small, thermal
Exhaust Pipe Weakness.
It has the quality
of That's No Moon,
but it does not have a
Race of Enslaved Minions,
or a Secret Escape Route,
or Sharks with Laser Beams.
Now when I originally
wrote this problem in 2008,
there was another quality
that very important.
It was a giant Laser, and it
did have that property, as did
Dr. Evil's Moon Base,
but that was removed
to make it easier to solve.
So we're going to solve it
without the giant laser,
that we can just have the
Sharks with Laser Beams.
So Mark Vader has gone to
Ackbar's Emporium of New Evil
Strongholds, which are
listed on the left,
and he's trying to
figure out the best
way to get from his
current stronghold
to his goal stronghold,
the 603 Fortress, which
has the admirable qualities of
no small thermal Exhaust Pipe
Weakness, and it still
has That's No Moon.
It has a Race of
Enslaved Minions,
and a Secret Escape Route,
and Sharks with Laser Beams.
So it's got everything you
would want and no weakness.
However, he can only move
between fortresses that
have exactly one difference.
Fortunately, Mark remembers
how to perform the search
techniques he learned in
6.034 from his mentor, Emperor
Palpatine.
So we've got several
fortresses here.
We've got the
Depth-First Search Star.
We've also got
Shaoul Ghoul, which
has the qualities,
basically, of That's
No Moon, and none of
the other qualities.
Dol Guldur here, has got the
Exhaust Pipe Weakness somehow,
despite being
Sauron's stronghold.
It's not a moon, and it
has those enslaved minions.
I guess the Orcs are enslaved.
Moonraker, here, only has
the Exhaust Pipe Weakness,
so it's not very good.
But James Bond didn't
need to deal with stuff.
Zeal Underwater
Palace has That's
No Moon and a
Secret Escape Route.
Zeromus' Lunar Core has
an Exhaust Pipe Weakness
and a Race of Enslaved Minions.
Whalers of the Moon Ride has
the Exhaust Pipe Weakness,
Race of Enslaved Minions,
and Sharks with Laser Beams.
6.03 Fortress we've
already been over.
Atlantis has all qualities
except for a Secret Escape
Route.
Willy Wonka's Factory
has some of everything.
It is, after all,
Willy Wonka's Factory.
Highlight, the Race of Enslaved
Minions, the Oompa Loompas.
And Dr. Evil's Moon
Base is only missing
That's No Moon, because it is a
moon, because it's a moon base.
So if you got all
the references that
were used in making those
fortresses, I'm sorry.
There's nothing
I can do for you.
Now, Mark, being a
clever evil overlord,
realizes that he can produce
a graph of the exploration
choices with edges
joining strongholds that
differ by just one feature.
So although this
is a graph here,
as Patrick often says-- and you
get to hear again right now--
search is about choice,
not just about maps.
So we're not moving around
anywhere in the real world,
but we certainly are
going to move around
this graph to pick between
these many stronghold choices.
How can we decide
where to travel?
Well, we're about to find out.
So we've got this
lovely graph right here,
and now we're going to get
to do depth-first search
on the graph.
Now there's a lot of
ways to do search,
and you've seen
Patrick do it, you
may have seen some people
do it in recitation.
And I'm going to offer you guys
a unique opportunity to see me
do search in one of several
ways, or possibly more.
I have the tried
and true method.
You have the queue,
or agenda, or whatever
you want to call it.
You keep track of
it at every level.
You make damn sure that
everything you're doing
is right.
It takes a long time, and
you get the answer right.
Or there's one where you
only work with the goal tree,
and you draw it really fast,
and you might make a mistake,
but it's going to
solve it more quickly.
So who would rather see the
reliable, but slower, approach?
Who would rather see the faster,
but less reliable, approach?
All right.
Monte Carlo people here,
rather than Las Vegas.
If you don't know
what that is, you'll
learn it in algorithms class.
All right.
Then there's a third
approach that I probably
won't show you unless there's
overwhelming favor for it.
That is the approach
that is manically fast
and will solve depth-first
search in no time at all,
but it is very likely
to make mistakes.
That is the approach
that I use when
solving depth-first search.
I've used it enough times that I
don't make mistakes that often,
but even I still do.
So does anyone want
to see that one?
OK.
Not that many people.
Well, it doesn't take
much time, but I'm
just afraid that if I show it
you, that you'll be like, ooh,
that's the only way to do it.
So we'll save that for
later if we have more time.
It essentially, for people
that are interested,
involves just using
your chalk or finger
to trace through
the tree really fast
and figure out what it's doing
by drawing little tiny lines.
It is very fast, but
it's not very accurate.
And you have shown, basically,
no work if you get it wrong,
so shame on you.
OK.
Well, let's do the
somewhat faster way
where we don't draw
out the entire agenda,
and then people who were
the almost nobody who
raised their hand for
that way can check it out
in tutorial the way that
you do it using the agenda.
So let's do it
using the goal tree.
So it's a bit faster that way.
So we're going to start,
starting at S, the start node,
and going to G, the goal node.
That's a standard
notation, but make sure
that when you're
taking the test,
you check to make sure
where the start node is,
where the goal node is.
It's pretty much an
asshole move to have
a G node that isn't
the goal node,
but sometimes there
won't be an S node.
That's a pretty good
clue that something else
is the start node.
Now there's a few little
white star ideas that we have,
or silver star
ideas, for search.
One is lexicography.
What it lexicography?
Who cares?
Well, the most famous
lexicographer I know of
is Samuel Johnson, who wrote
a really famous dictionary.
And the only reason we
care about it in this class
is because you'll always
see the instructions "break
ties in lexicographic order."
And then you might
be like, wow, that's
really rather a wordy word,
or a sesquipedalion word,
or whatever really long word
you want to use to describe
the word "lexicographic."
What the heck does it mean?
Basically, it means
alphabetical order,
like you would do
in a dictionary.
So for instance, in alphabetical
order, A comes before B.
So you would go to A before
B. No, even beyond that point,
there's several ways to do
a lexicographic tiebreak.
And it's not always
consistent between algorithms
how you would do a
lexicographic tiebreaker.
In the most recent
time that Patrick
was kind of randomly
talking to the staff,
he made it clear that the way
he would like us to do it,
and therefore, the way
we'd like you to do it,
is to tiebreak based on the
very latest nodes at the end.
So you might say, that's
not really lexicographic.
Wouldn't SAB come before
SGA in the dictionary?
And my answer to you
is, yes, it would.
Yes, yes, it definitely would.
However, that is
apparently what we're
doing, according to the last
thing that Patrick said,
and we will keep you
updated if he decides
to go back to dictionary order.
So that's lexicography.
You might be wondering
what the picture here is.
Well, this is our
friend, the ouroboros.
Long has it been a
symbol in alchemy
of infinity, eternity, or
maybe a sort of infinite energy
engine, turning iron into gold.
But today, unfortunately,
the ouroboros
is an endangered species
because no biting your own tail
in 6.034.
A lot of people
mess up from this.
It's an honest mistake.
I mean, we've gotten some
emails from staff members who
couldn't solve one
of the problems
because they forgot about this.
So it's OK if you forget, but
try your best to remember.
No biting your own tail
is the only smart thing
our system does.
You'll remember last week when
we were talking about rules,
and we were saying that the rule
system is not a smart creature.
It doesn't know that
"not Polly is dead"
should be the same as
"Polly is not dead",
or something like that.
It's too dumb to
figure that out.
Well, this system is also
dumb, but one thing it knows
is that Patrick really hates
if the same node appears twice
within the same path.
And it will destroy
that immediately,
before even adding
it to the queue.
It's gone.
It's not considered.
It's out of there.
So very important,
sad ouroboros,
no biting your own tail.
All right.
So now that I've
gotten through that,
let's actually solve the problem
with some depth-first search.
How will we do that?
Well, we're not going to use
the queue, as popular demand,
we're going to use a goal tree.
So we'll start at node S. What
are our choices at node S?
Well, I'm going to
force you guys to help.
So it won't be quite as
fast, but it'll be fun.
So what are our
choices at node S?
You.
AUDIENCE: Me?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: A or B?
PROFESSOR: Not quite,
and this is something
I like about this problem.
You got most of them.
Do you see that there
might be another choice?
Everyone?
Yeah, C. This is
a big problem that
has happened on a few different
quiz problems where there's
a sort of a grid that
looks like a tree,
or a graph that looks
like a tree, where
people aren't as willing to
go up as they are to go down.
You can see it on some of the
other past quiz problems too.
Make sure that you
check the connectivity,
and also note that unless
otherwise specified--
and I don't think we've really
done this much-- the little
connecting edges in our
graphs are bidirectional.
You'll see a big
arrow, and probably
instructions written at
least eight font sizes higher
than all the rest
of them, and bold,
if we're going to do something
different for this quiz.
It happens that they
do it sometimes,
where I'll just say in
recitation, we never do this.
And then on the
quiz, they do it.
But it will be in giant bold
letters, which also leads me
to another silver star
idea that I forgot
to tell you guys last week.
So I hope people
didn't ditch out on me,
like, oh, Mark's boring.
We won't come next week.
And then miss this one because
it just came to my mind.
That is, read the instructions.
It is a very important
thing for the quizzes,
and Patrick will,
in a later lecture,
tell you guys, ask
why five times,
and he'll explain why
that's a gold star idea.
My parallel to this is read
the instructions five times.
Maybe not five, maybe three
or four, but at least three.
Read the instructions.
Read them again.
Then read them a third
time only paying attention
to whatever is bold
and eight sizes larger
than all the other ones, cause
there's going to be something
there that's that size.
And it going to be the
thing that everyone misses.
So make sure you're
not everyone,
and you read the
instructions a lot of times.
But anyway, so yeah,
we've got it right.
S goes to A, B, and C. OK.
We're looking at A, B,
and C as possibilities.
Everyone, help me make the
lexicographic tiebreak.
Where do we go?
AUDIENCE: A.
PROFESSOR: A. That's right.
Actually, I'll call on
you guys for other ones,
but that first step
is pretty simple.
We could have everyone
do it together.
Everyone, A only leads to?
AUDIENCE: D.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Why doesn't it
lead to S as well?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: No biting
your own tail.
Everyone's right.
Good job, everyone.
All right.
S leads to these three.
You go to A, go to D. Dead end.
Backtrack.
OK.
When we backtrack,
we backtrack up to A.
There's no other children.
We backtrack up to S.
Where will we go now?
AUDIENCE: B.
PROFESSOR: B. It's the
next one alphabetically.
All right.
B can't go to S,
so it only goes to?
AUDIENCE: H.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
When we're at H, we can go to?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: F or I. That's right.
You guys get this.
Depth-first search is easy.
All right.
But we choose?
F. That's right.
When we're at F, we can go to?
E and J. That's right.
We'll choose?
E. When we're at
E, we can go to?
We can go to C. It's not
on this particular path.
People are correct when
they say C. When we go to C,
we can go to nowhere.
We're dead.
Backtrack.
We backtrack.
We can't do anything
at E. We go to F.
Now I forgot to tell you guys,
but this is an important note.
Someone's going
to get this wrong.
It's going to be one of you.
Look around you, all
through the room.
At least one of you
is going to do this.
So, now I'm going to
tell you not to do this,
and then hopefully,
that will still
be true, but for fewer people.
When I went to D, and then I
backtracked, and I went to S,
how many times did I backtrack?
Once.
I backtracked once.
This would have
been more obvious
if we were doing the
really slow boring agenda
way, or queue way, because
when we got to SAD,
and we expanded it, and
there was nothing left,
we throw it off the
top of the queue,
and go to the next
thing on the queue.
And it turns out the next
thing on the queue is SB.
That step was only taken once.
Since we're using the goal
tree, which is faster,
it looked like we did
two, but we didn't.
And if you use the queue, you'll
see that because it'll go S,
and then we expand that, SASBSC.
SBIC OK.
We expand SA.
SADSBSC.
We expand SAD.
It's dead.
SBSC.
One backtrack.
We're back at SB.
So, so far we've
done two, not four.
It's pretty intuitive to
say that you did two there.
It turns out you didn't
because of the algorithm that's
backing what lets us do
this goal tree search.
So try to make sure you're
not the one who says two.
And I, on the other
hand, will try
to make sure that we don't take
off too many points if you do.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So any time
you backtrack, regardless
of how much it chains,
any backtracking
is just considered once.
PROFESSOR: It is always going
to be considered one step.
It's possible to backtrack
two times in a row.
Like, if B didn't go
to anything, instead
of going to H, then we
might backtrack twice
before we got to SC.
Generally, anytime you draw
a swizzle, if you're like me,
and you draw a swizzle--
I suggest the swizzles.
They're very nice little things.
But any time you draw a
swizzle on your graph,
you have backtracked once.
You could even write
BT next to the swizzle,
and go back and count those,
or even just count the swizzles
at the end.
You've got it.
You got the answer.
Because they often ask, how
many times have you backtracked?
All right.
So good questions, everyone.
So anyway, we backtracked from
C. Nothing at E. We go back.
We were at F. So
we were at SBHF.
We go to J. It's
the only choice.
At J, we can only go to?
AUDIENCE: I.
PROFESSOR: And at I,
we can only go to?
And we win.
It's not an optimal search,
so as soon as we see anything
with a G on the queue, boom.
Winner.
All right.
And we're done.
We did it.
That wasn't too bad.
For those of you who are
vaguely interested in seeing
how I would do it the
really super fast way,
it goes something like this.
All right.
ABC.
A comes first.
Only D. Backtrack.
All right.
B comes first.
H. F comes first.
E. C. Nothing.
Backtrack.
We came that way.
JIG.
So that's the really fast
way to do depth-first search.
Don't do that, kids.
We don't like--
well, maybe you can.
If you get it right,
we're not going
to take off points usually.
Generally, when we say
draw the goal tree below,
it's just assigned
partial credit.
However, we are pretty
strict about that.
If anything is wrong,
except for maybe, like, OK,
you write everything exactly
right, and forget G at the end.
If anything that's not
completely understandable
is wrong, you will probably
lose all of the points,
and it'll be a lot of points if
you don't draw the goal tree.
I will emphasize drawing the
goal tree is a good idea.
All right.
So now let's do a
breadth-first search.
Before we do the breadth-first
search on this tree,
I will tell you guys that
there is also a fast way
to do the breadth-first
search which is less risky,
and it really depends
on how nice they
are about what they ask for.
In this case, the
breadth-first search question
asks, what path does Mark find
using breadth-first search?
Rather than saying,
what nodes does
he expand in order,
or anything like that.
That is important.
If that question
is asked you, there
is a trick that will let you
solve it very, very quickly.
In fact, faster than
depth-first search.
You can solve it by inspection
in about 30 seconds.
Does anyone know
what the answer is?
What path did he find?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
So the answer is?
On this graph, the answer is?
AUDIENCE: SBHIG.
PROFESSOR: SBHIG.
That's the answer.
You would have your five points.
Did people see that?
It doesn't always work, so we're
going to actually solve it.
But did everyone see
that sometimes you
can get away with not doing it?
Because breadth-first
search is guaranteed
to give you the path, as we
heard correctly, with the least
number of jumps, and if there
are more than one that tie
with the least number of jumps,
you can just lexicographically
figure it out, in this case
with actual dictionary order.
But SBHIG is the only one.
Let's do an actual
breadth-first search though,
so we can feel better
about ourselves.
OK.
So you've got S, and S goes
to, as we saw before, ABC.
Maybe that doesn't have
to go quite so high.
All right.
As we saw before, S goes to ABC.
And you already told
me that A goes to D,
and you told me that B goes
to H. But what does C go to?
E. That's right.
As you can see,
we're expanding it
level by level, left to right.
All right.
So SAD, were does SAD go to?
SAD goes to nowhere.
It's dead.
SBH.
Now, wait.
You might say, wait a minute.
Patrick said that we're
using this weird dictionary
order where E is at the end
that comes before H. That's
our tiebreak order,
but it turns out
that breadth-first search
and depth-first search
don't sort in any way.
It's very important.
They don't sort the paths that
are currently on the queue.
So you're going to just go
left to right, left to right,
left to right.
And only at each node are
you going to break ties
in lexicographic order.
All right?
So SBH.
H goes to, as we already
know, F and I. E, we
think we already
know, but we don't
quite because this is E coming
from the other direction.
E, this time goes
to F. That's right.
Well, actually, you
guys do already know it.
All right.
Great.
Now we come over here.
HF goes to, as we
already know, E and J.
I goes to, as we don't already
know, HI goes to G and J.
That's right.
And as it turns out, by
an implementation detail,
we're done.
Questions?
Does it not expand depth at all?
Now this is an
implementation detail.
It's perfectly
sane and reasonable
to make a breadth-first
search that
likes to finish its entire
level that it's working on.
However, in our
implementation, and we
would have seen this if we
had been pedantic and drawn
out the entire queue--
that's another reason why
drawing out the entire queue
is, as I said, more reliable.
In our implementation, since
it's not an optimal search,
the moment anywhere
on the queue,
you add something with a
G at the end, you finish.
And because of the fact that the
way breadth-first search does
its mojo, is that
it adds everything
to the end of the queue.
That's how it does it
level by level, right?
It adds it to the end of the
queue, instead of the front.
Well, then you'll add it
to the end of the queue,
and then you will have
it on the queue with a G.
So you won't have to do SCEF.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering,
so the breadth-first search,
there was no backtracking
[INAUDIBLE] had no other--
PROFESSOR: Ah.
That's a good question.
So the question was, so for
the breadth-first search,
there was no backtracking.
D died.
Why didn't we
backtrack or something?
The answer to that one is,
for breadth-first search,
backtracking doesn't really,
it isn't really a thing,
like it is for
depth-first search.
Why?
Well, because
breadth-first search,
we're sending our infinite
monkeys down every path.
In depth-first search,
we're really focused in now.
We're like, we
want to get there.
We want to get there.
Ooh, this way, this
way, this way, this way.
And might have
gone the wrong way,
and then we hit a dead
end, we're like, oh, crap.
And we go backwards.
But for breadth-first
search, we really
are like an evil overlord.
And we're like Mark Vader
saying, storm troopers,
go every direction.
And then from there, go
every other direction.
And so, even though, yes, when
we got to D, some of the storm
troopers hit a dead end, and
probably it was reflective,
and they shot it, and hit
themselves or something
like that.
Meanwhile, the storm
troopers we sent to B
and C are still fine, so
we don't need to backtrack.
AUDIENCE: Cause there are,
like, other troops going down
the tree.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there are
other troops going down
the tree in every direction.
Whereas in the
depth-first search,
we only sent-- we were
like, there are definitely
no droids on this escape pod.
Send everyone this
straight direction,
and we only sent
them to A and D.
And then, so we had to backtrack
because we hit a dead end.
Does that make sense?
Another question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
in this breadth-first search,
did lexicographic order
ever come into play?
The answer is yes, in a
very subtle and sneaky way.
Which is, I wrote E before
J, F before I, and G
before J. If I was not
using lexicographic order,
it might have been
reasonable to write,
for instance, when
I was expanding I,
to write J before G because
J was higher up on the tree
or something like that.
But the only way
it came into play
is that I wrote them left to
right in alphabetical order
every time, and I wrote ABC.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: We see
the F node twice.
Suppose that the goal node
wasn't reached [INAUDIBLE],
then you would have
visited F again.
PROFESSOR: And we would
have visited F again.
That's correct.
The question is,
F is listed twice.
So if we hadn't
reached the goal node,
let's say that down
there, after I is Z,
and after Z is the
goal node, then
would we have visited F again?
The answer is yes.
As I said, this is the
approach that throws
your troops every possible way.
So there's storm troopers
going from E to F,
and there's storm troopers
going from H to F,
and they're going everywhere.
Now there is a way
to cut down on this.
You could do breadth-first
search with an extended list.
If you did do
breadth-first search
with an extended
list, that would
be sort of equivalent to as
soon as you expand one node,
as soon you send storm troopers
out of I to look at G and J,
one of them stays at I, and if
any other storm troopers come
to I, and they're like, we
want to see what's past I,
he's like, no, no, no.
We've already sent troops
past I. We've got this.
Go back home.
It's OK.
There are no rebels
here, but it might
be Han Solo dressed
up as a storm trooper,
as we'll see in
the next problem.
Where our extended
list screws us over.
But for this problem,
do you see what I mean?
With an extended list,
we could avoid this
because the extended
list basically
says, once I've expanded
and searched past here,
don't do it again.
But if you don't have one,
yeah, you'll do F twice.
In fact, didn't we do
something twice here?
Oh, it turns out we didn't.
But we easily could have.
We almost did E twice.
We almost did F twice.
It turns out we didn't,
but we could have.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] for the
implementation of the queue
that when you expand
I, that both G and J
were added simultaneously
and in lexicographic order?
Or is there a piece where it
would be [INAUDIBLE] order,
G got added before J, so
hence, it stopped [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Ha.
That is a very good question
that provokes a minor change.
The question is,
when you expand SBHI,
is SBHIG added
before SBHIJ because
of lexicographic
ordering, or are they
both added at the same time?
The answer is, simultaneous.
When you do the
expansion, you instantly
receive say, a list maybe, or
whatever data structure you
like, containing
all of the children,
and they get appended to
the queue at once in order.
So you will receive all of them.
I suppose you could create
some kind of search problem
where you have, like, an
adversary node, like a wumpus,
or you're hunting a wumpus.
And if you don't want to add
the exact wumpus to your search
tree, or you lose.
You only want to add the
one next to the wumpus.
I don't know.
I'm making this up.
And unfortunately,
you would have
to add all the children at once.
Our current algorithm does
not add one at a time.
All right.
So we've done a
breadth-first search.
Great.
Now we're going to do
some optimal search.
That is going to
require me to draw
a slightly different graph.
I will draw it on what is
left of the bottom here.
And then we'll solve it on what
is left of the bottom here.
All right.
Mark has his new
stronghold, and he wants
to invade parallel universes.
Now he's programmed
his evil supercomputer
to find the shortest
path of jumps
from his starting universe
to the goal universe,
G. It takes a certain
amount of energy
to move from
universe to universe
based on the differing factors
between those universes.
Like maybe in one
universe, a butterfly
didn't flap its wings in China,
whereas in the other universe,
sentient reptiles
rule the earth.
And so, Mark's
supercomputer has tried
to create a heuristic
value that determines
how different the universes
are to guess, sort of, how
much energy it's going to
take to get from his start
universe, S, to his
goal universe, G,
given that currently his armies
are at a particular universe.
In other words, OK, it's
not A you put in search,
but dammit, we're going
to have a heuristic
distance to the goal.
And we're going to have
a graph with distances.
So let's see what it looks like.
All right.
And down here is G. So this
otherwise unassuming heart
shape hides an evil
invasion force.
So let's see.
The distance here is 100.
The distance here is 3, 4.
The distance here is 4.
The distance here is
50, 50, 14, 4, 16, 16.
Oh sorry, these are connected.
30 and 10.
The heuristic values are 0
at the start node, 50 at B,
60 at A, 55 at C, 50
at D, 56 at E, 50 at F,
0 at G because it's
the goal node, 39 at H.
I'll draw the little H smaller.
And 0 at I. Well, after all, I
goes right to G. It can be 0.
It'll be great.
OK.
Now, this time Mark is
trying to conserve the energy
of his parallel universe jump.
That, understandably,
takes a lot of energy.
So he needs to program
in the shortest
number of universe jumps that
will get him to the goal.
He doesn't mean the
least number of jumps.
He means the least amount
of energy on these edges.
He's not interested in
getting to this new world,
and not having
enough energy left
to blast the crap out of it.
So we need to find
the shortest path.
So first Mark programs a
simple branch and bound search.
He adds in an extended
list to his branch
and bound just to make
it a little bit faster.
As usual, he breaks
ties of equal length
in lexicographic order.
So let's list the nodes
that Mark's computer adds
to the extended list in order.
Distances are shown
next to the edges.
Ignore the number in
parentheses for now.
They are heuristics, and
we're not using them.
So that brings me
to another point
that I'd like to
drive home before we
go for the home stretch
and solve these problems.
What the heck is the difference
between branch and bound
and A*?
OK.
I like to liken it
to the following.
I probably should have, I'll
make this a silver star idea.
OK.
The silver star idea is pizza.
It doesn't really
look like pizza,
but that's the silver star idea.
Branch and bound
is a cheese pizza.
It's simple.
If you order it
for a large group
event of college students,
they will eat it,
and things will be OK.
Now A* search is some kind of
meat lover's or supreme pizza.
Maybe a meat lover's pizza.
It's got all these
extra toppings.
A lot of people are
really going to like it.
It might be better.
But then you've
got a vegetarian,
and everything's screwed up.
So basically, A* is just branch
and bound with some extra
toppings added on.
In this case, one of the
toppings is an extended list,
an extended list
which we'll see keeps
track of where we've passed
through and already expanded
out, and it never goes back.
The other topping that we're
going to add is a heuristic.
A heuristic tells
us about how far
we think we have left
until we're at the end,
so we don't go through really
short paths that go completely
in the wrong direction.
All right?
Between the two of those,
we get our supreme pizza,
but sometimes, as
we'll see, they sort of
mess each other up.
So one of the toppings
just doesn't go well
with the other one.
Maybe someone doesn't Hawaiian.
They think that the ham doesn't
go well with the pineapple.
So let's do a branch and bound
that just has an extended list.
Maybe we've got some green
peppers on this pizza.
This is going to be safe.
All right.
So we're going to list the
nodes as to the extended list,
and the way we're going
to do that is, well,
you guys said you like
goal tree more than queue,
so let's do it with a goal tree.
So we've got S, and
as we already know,
S is the only path.
Our current length at S is 0.
That's the lowest of all of
our lengths on the tree cause
it's the only length.
So we go to A, B, and C.
It may be hard to see,
so the length of SA is 100.
The length of SB is--
AUDIENCE: You mean ABEF?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: Oh.
You're right.
It's a different tree.
I was doing A, B, and
C from the other tree.
Thank you, friends, for
correcting my foolishness.
The length of SB is 3.
It is a different tree.
I was trying to save
work that wound up
creating more because someone's
going to be confused by this.
So the length of A, B, E,
and F are 100, 3, 14, and 14.
Which one do we choose?
Lexicographically, it's A.
We choose that one, right?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: F is going to be 14.
That' a 1.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: 4.
4.
PROFESSOR: Oh, it's 4?
I wrote this problem.
I should know it.
You're right.
F is 4.
My apologies once more.
That's what I get.
All right.
I'm going to stand
over here from now
on when I write over there.
OK.
So which one of these
are we going to choose?
Even with the 4, we're going
to choose B. That's right.
Lexicographic be damned.
It's only for tiebreaks.
We want the shortest path.
Our special thing
with branch and bound
is we take the currently
shortest path, whatever it is.
Great.
So we expand B.
Fortunately, and I'm
pretty sure I've got this
correct this time-- oh wait,
I've got an even better idea.
I'll just take this
little hand sheet with me,
and then I don't have
to look at that at all.
OK.
So once we expand B, B goes to
D. Our path length from B to D
is 4, so what will we write
next to little G here?
7.
That's right.
We add them all together.
I'm going to ask you guys
again the next time we
do this with the
heuristics, which
is going to be the next
part of the problem,
and someone's going to give
me the wrong answer next time.
So stay tuned for that.
All right.
So we've got SBD.
We've got all of these.
Where do we go next?
F. That's right,
because currently 4
is the shortest because you
guys corrected me correctly.
So SF.
4 is the shortest.
F only goes to H. And what
do we write next to the H?
20.
That's right.
16 plus 4, 20.
All right.
Where's our current shortest?
It's the D, SBD.
All right?
So SBD.
D only goes to I,
and we've got a 57.
Wait a minute.
I want to get this problem
right, so we better
actually write
the extended list,
[INAUDIBLE] because that's the
only thing they're asking us
for.
So first we extended S.
Then we extended B. Then we
extended F. Then we
extended D. All right.
So far, so good.
And I have the answer key, so
I know we're doing it right.
OK.
What are we doing next?
E. That's right.
So we extend E. E goes to
H. And when E goes to H,
we've got a length of 30.
All right.
Who's our winner now?
Which H?
SFH.
That's right.
SFH is length 20.
Oh yeah, of course I
should write an E in here.
I always forget to do that.
SFH is length 20,
so we will extend H,
and I'm going to write
it here preemptively.
When we extend H over here, H
only goes to I, with length 50.
Great.
What's the next shortest?
The next shortest is the other
H. However, will we expand it?
You guessed that because I
asked that question in that way.
You knew the answer was no.
Why don't we expand it?
It's already on
the extended list.
That's right.
So since it's already
on the extended list,
this one dies a horrible death.
I like writing an X through it
instead of writing a swizzle
at the bottom.
You can do whatever you want.
All right, it's gone.
It's not a choice.
What's the next best one?
SFHI.
That's right.
That goes to G, and
the length is 60.
And we've extended I. All right.
Question is, are we done?
The people who say
no, I like you.
You're smart.
You realize that
just because the G
is on there, that we can't end.
However, the people who
said yes, you are either
oblivious or really,
really smart,
and I'm going to
choose to assume you're
all really, really smart because
the really, really smart people
said, OK.
Yes, we're not quite
done just because we
added a G. We
still have to check
to make sure there are no
lengths with shorter path,
but look.
The only one with
a shorter path is
I, which is already
on the extended list.
So actually, we are done.
Double check.
We've got it.
So these are the paths
we extended in order,
and our final path is?
Everyone.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
SFHIG.
I claim that is
the correct path.
However, Mark is frustrated
by branch and bound's speed.
I don't know.
I wasn't that frustrated.
Seemed pretty good.
But Mark is frustrated by
branch and bound's speed,
so he reprograms his
computer to use A*.
Mark counts the number of
subspace anomalies between each
universe and the goal, and uses
this count as the heuristic
for A*.
These numbers are
in parentheses.
Hopefully, you can read them.
Yes?
Oh, we've got a question.
Right here?
AUDIENCE: So, given
the implementation,
you said that you expand
all possible nodes.
So why doesn't I go to C and
D, as well as [INAUDIBLE]?
Like, why doesn't it
expand to [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
That is a very good question.
And the answer is, a
very simple answer.
You guys tricked me.
No, but I should have been
able to figure it out.
It does go to C and D. The
correct tree, which we wouldn't
have lost points for having
the incorrect tree here
cause we did get the
correct answer, yes.
The reason why it is, that same
reason that very first time I
asked someone something,
he didn't remember the C.
It's easy to forget
to go up the tree.
It does actually have
a C and D. However,
they are horrendous paths.
They are 100 and 100
on their path length,
and so it doesn't matter.
But you were correct.
The official answer we
had up there is wrong.
AUDIENCE: Would the D get added
to this list of children that's
already in the extended list?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
The question is, would the
D get added to the children?
After all, it's already
in the extended list.
The answer is, we search
for, and remove, and kill
all of the attempts to
extend something that's
already on the expanded list at
the time we try to expand it.
The time we try to
expand it is only
when it's on the
front of the queue
because it's the
currently shortest path.
So that means they get added.
It's just that when it
comes time to expand it,
it will get crossed
off no matter what.
Turns out, it escaped
execution because of the fact
that we never expanded it.
AUDIENCE: So H should
go to E as well?
PROFESSOR: So H should go to
E as well, is the question.
The answer is yes.
H should go to E as well.
A lot slipped past me this time.
H should go to E as well,
with a length of 36,
and it dies there.
This one will
actually be checked,
so it actually does
make a difference.
If we ask how many times was
a node executed due to already
being on the extended list?
Very good.
Very good notice.
It should be on there.
We'll get it right next time.
All right, everyone.
So I'm working
together with you.
I made the mistake too.
Easy one to make.
It can mess you up.
It didn't this time.
We're going to
get it-- question?
AUDIENCE: If G's
the goal at the end,
and you get G in your outcomes,
and you know the number that's
shorter than
everything else, do you
have to actually extend at G?
PROFESSOR: So, the question
is, do you actually extend G?
Should we even put G
in the extended list?
The answer is, the
answer to that question
is, it is a matter of taste.
And in the questions
where we, in my opinion,
rather foolishly, asked how
many nodes were extended,
rather than ask you
to write them out,
we generally accept the
answer where you didn't extend
or where you did extend G.
It's an implementation detail.
You can either have a
fail safe that, as soon
as it sees G at the beginning
of the list, says, we're out.
We're not going to extend.
We're done.
We win.
Or a fail safe that, when you're
about to extend something,
and you go into the
extension process,
and it sees that it
ends in G, that it wins.
So it is a matter of taste.
If you kind of like to
watch your little guy
doing the search win,
and have an S and a G,
you can put it on.
If you don't, you
can not put it on.
We won't take off points
for whether or not
it has a G at the end
because clearly, if you
did all the other crazy
stuff correct, well,
you could have written
in a G if you wanted to.
I think, unless there's someone
who mis-solves the problem
right at the end, is like,
oh, who cares about G?
Oh no, it's stuck.
It's a dead end.
We lose.
But that would be
probably pretty rare.
So let's solve the A*.
So I'm not going to make
the same mistake twice.
We go from S to ABEF.
And S, by the way,
had a value of 0.
All right.
What is the value at A?
Well, I think it's 160.
The question is, how
do we calculate this?
Well, it's the path
that we've traveled
so far plus the heuristic
value at the final node.
This is why someone's going to
give me the wrong answer at BD,
but let's see.
So we have 160 here.
OK.
So SB.
What is the
heuristic value here?
We've got 3 for the path, and 50
for the heuristic, so it's 53.
SE.
What have we got here?
We've got 14 for the path, 56
for the heuristic, so it's 70.
All right.
SF.
We've got 4 for the path,
50 for the heuristic, 54.
OK.
Who's our winner?
It's B again.
Barely, but it is the winner.
Extended list up here.
SB.
All right.
B, as we saw, goes only to D.
What is the value that
I should write here?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: OK.
I am happy I heard all the
things that I expected to hear.
I heard the correct
answer, which is 57.
I also heard someone say 107.
So why is it 57, and not 107?
Someone does it
this way every time.
Do not add up all the
heuristics along the way.
I will try to explain to
you why you would never
want to do that.
The heuristic value
at any given node
says, given that I'm here,
how much work do I think
I have left to get to the end?
All right?
It's sort of like, let's guess
the last few nodes in the path
that we haven't done out yet.
So you can see why it
would be bad to add that
for every node in your list
because then you're double
counting all of the last nodes.
So add the path so far to
the very final heuristic.
That's 3 plus 4 plus the
50 that's with D is 57.
So our current winner, then,
is 54, with F. Just the same
as last time.
F goes to H. And what's
our total value at H?
20 plus, that's a 39, 59.
So who wins now?
D, with 57.
But we extended F, yes.
All right.
So D was 57.
So D was not one of the ones
that I tricked myself with.
D only goes to I.
What's our value at I?
I think our value is 57
because I has a heuristic of 0.
Yes.
I has a heuristic of 0.
Our value at I is 57.
OK?
And I extended D.
Who's the winner now?
I?
OK.
So I is the winner.
With I as the winner, we extend
I. I goes to C, D. Ha ha.
Good call, whoever back there
figured out my secret error
before.
C, D, and G.
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: C, H, and G?
Oh, you're right.
We already went to D. Aha.
C, H, and G. You're correct.
Everyone see that?
C, H, and G. Absolutely right.
I goes to C, H, and G. So
the path to C, H, and G
is a hard path.
To C, we got, what did we have?
57 plus 50 is 127.
Oh, and by the way,
C, G, and H. We've
got to do it in
lexicographic order.
So 127 to C. To G, we have 67.
And to H, we have 87.
So who wins now?
H. H, with 59.
That's right.
H, with 59.
And as we already
know, cause it was
the winner last
time, H, with 59,
goes to I, which
has, I believe, 50.
Well, it's still gets added.
Remember?
We're only going to kill
it when it gets extended.
So who's the shortest?
So you were a step ahead,
whoever asked me that question.
Who's the shortest?
H also goes to E.
Absolutely right.
H also goes to E. I was
getting ahead of myself here.
H also goes to E with
a length of extra 16.
So we've got 20 plus
16 is 36 plus 56 is 92.
All right.
That's good.
So who's the shortest?
I is the shortest.
Do we extend it?
No.
It's on the extended list.
All right.
Who's the shortest now?
It's hard to read, but the
shortest is this 67 on the G.
So we're done.
We win.
Our path is SBDIG.
Yeah, for A*.
It gets the right answer, right?
No.
Unfortunately not.
So what happened here?
Why did we not get
the right answer?
Be as specific as possible.
What are people saying
about heuristics?
AUDIENCE: [CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: All right.
People are saying the
heuristic must be consistent.
That is both correct and
specific, so I applaud you.
Too easy to say the
heuristic was inadmissible.
It actually was completely
admissible everywhere.
So that leads us into our
very last point for the day.
What the hell are these
heuristic consistency
and admissibility things,
and why do I care?
Well, the reason why you care
is many fold, one of which
is that it's almost
guaranteed to be on the quiz.
But what are they?
Admissibility is a check
at every point to make sure
your heuristic at
that point, which
is supposed to be an
estimate of how much work
you have left to do, is always
an underestimate or an accurate
estimate.
It can never be an overestimate.
Why not?
Well, as Patrick showed you
with his mostly correct example
in lecture, if it's
an overestimate,
it's never going
to expand that node
cause it's going to think, you
know, if you write one million
as a heuristic,
it's going to think
it needs to do one million
after it's done going that way.
It's not going to
want to go that way.
All right?
So it's always got to
be an underestimate
or an equal estimate.
But let's say that
you, at the quiz,
and you forget
Mark told me this.
You didn't bring any notes.
You're just having
a brain freeze.
You're like, oh no.
Is it supposed to
be an overestimate
or an underestimate?
I can't remember which one.
How can I figure it out?
I propose you the following
calm, soothing mantra slash
sutra that will
help protect you.
Think to yourself of
the following question.
We know that A* sometimes
messes up with the heuristic.
Does branch and bound
always get it right?
Yes.
What heuristic values
does branch and bound
add everywhere?
0.
Right?
It has no heuristic.
It essentially adds 0.
Is 0 an overestimate
or an underestimate?
An underestimate.
Therefore, since branch
and bound always works,
the one you're looking
for is an underestimate.
And I know from when I
was taking the class,
I always had a moment
where I had to spend, like,
two minutes convincing
myself, OK, I'm
going for underestimate,
not overestimate.
This will help.
It will take fewer than
two minutes to do that.
So what is consistency?
Consistency is a little
bit stronger of a claim.
When you claim that a
graph is consistent,
what you're saying is,
between any two nodes,
or to do it more simply,
between any two adjacent nodes,
the distance between
the heuristics
is less than the distance
between the nodes.
In other words,
admissibility is a sort
of, like, consistency
between every node in G.
Whereas consistency is
consistency between every node
and every other node.
All right?
Consistency is a stronger claim.
Any graph that's consistent
is always admissible.
Any graph that is inadmissible
is always inconsistent.
That's the contrapositive.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Less than or
less than or equal to?
PROFESSOR: Equal to is still OK.
Equal to is always OK.
That's great.
It's a perfect estimate.
But never greater.
Now, if a graph is
inconsistent, will you lose?
Will you lose?
Why is it called admissible,
then, if it's sometimes not
admissible?
Why do we lose?
The answer is the extended
list, and you see that here.
If a graph is admissible,
you will always
get the right answer
unless you use an extended
list because you're
checking from every node
to the goal node.
And you're sure that
your estimates are right.
But if estimates within
nodes aren't correct,
you might go through
them out of order,
and that violates
your assumption
that you made when
you decided to use
the extended list
that you would always
go through the
sub-graphs in order.
This graph is very expertly
crafted to do that to
you cause I might
as well be sort
of a bottleneck, goal node,
and I has an inconsistency.
There's a few other
inconsistencies in this graph,
but they don't do
anything to you.
In fact, even inadmissibilities
sometimes don't mess you up.
So you can't just say,
blindly, it's inadmissible,
so it will never work.
It might work.
It turns out the
only inconsistency
that matters here is not the
inconsistency between, say,
S and F. That doesn't
turn out to matter.
It's the inconsistency
between some of these nodes,
including I and H, specifically.
So have a good weekend.
Come in on Monday and
Tuesday to tutorial.
Ask about the queue
method, or other methods.
Ask about anything that's
niggling in your brain.
But hopefully, you
guys have got this.
You're going to do fine.